all right beautiful
a little tune in together some deep
breaths
hmm
just relaxing any tension away
[Music]
just tuning into
our
highest selves
and interacting with each other from
that space
from the space of
shambhala
the
spiritual kingdoms on earth already
being done
and from the heart
from unity from love
oh man
so
welcome everyone
welcome everybody yeah this is um gonna
be an exciting conversation um
because we're shooting this podcast for
both myself and atlas's podcast
individually but we're doing it all in
one episode
and um
which is
in itself unique i love that
it's so cool and it's nice because
when you do that
you have
simulation
and you have insights
and you have
the unique audiences on both channels
the unique like essence of both channels
so you and i will have like different
angles that we sort of take
on our channels
and
that's
that's exciting and then there'll be
some cross-pollination so people
visiting insights
from simulation people from insights vis
visiting simulation people from
simulation visiting insights
yeah yeah so zamir will you angle your
camera a little bit down so you're more
like me in the frame there we go thank
you yeah that looks great
i look like a floating head yeah
nice man um
yeah so we were talking about a little
bit i guess before well first of all
actually i want to address what you just
said because i i do i think that's like
the whole
intention of insights is that cross not
only cross-pollination but also like
this the shining of light like so i
spent a lot of my years as a recording
artist and the light was always on me
right like i was this spotlight kind of
like at least from my end of the um or
my
uh perception it was like always okay
well how you know being interviewed
um
and so this for me is kind of new um in
terms of podcasting and interviewing
other people and spotlighting them but
it's it's from such a
different place than where where music
was first of all but um it's very very
cool
in terms of
just having conversation for the sake of
conversation and selflessly sharing
stories like i think selflessly sharing
people's stories
um to to
like really like what i find is i have
such amazing conversations with people
and they enlighten me you know like
they're enlightening conversations and
like if if that can be shared with the
world and there's some sort of platform
that can just be built for that and
that's that that's really my
um my intention with insights is like to
give an insight into it's i i call it um
a loom or it's like shining light on the
illuminated ones
or like illuminating the illuminated
ones yeah yeah i heard that in the
intro in your animation intro and your
voiceover just
for
that to become the norm
and
specifically shining the light on the
illumined ones
and i feel like it would be important to
share what we
mean by that
and
from my perspective we mean
those that have found out who they are
and what they are
and then
feel the
peace and happiness that comes from that
realization which is like the sun
and illumins
and then they share that with
all
of creation
emanate that
and
they basically serve the rest of
creation
shifting more and more into the sun
themselves basically unblocking any
clouds nailed it yeah
nailed it nailed it um the sun is such a
big part of my uh i would say
just my journey in general it's been
very uh like it's been a metaphor that's
been since the beginning of my
hey oh
that's been around for me so that was
perfect i love that
nice yeah and that's and that's been
across all of the
mystic traditions
it's important to mention because
this is
without this is thousands of years old
what we're talking about it's
across all of the different traditions
mystic traditions around the planet
so each religion basically has a mystic
tradition that's about uniting with god
within
and
they
just that in itself
is answering the question
who am i and
what is i and
what is my true nature and just
doing that investigation
is like what they say in the traditions
just cutting through any clouds
or any of these onion layers that we've
built up of separation
or
lack
um is traditionally called ego or
if you really want to get metaphysical
location um
so any sense of being
located in the body
any sense of being your thoughts
any sense of
being
separate
really from
creation
from others
create generates
this
dis-ease
and then
it's aimed to be remedied through all of
creation's goodies like yeah yeah so
then i'll go buy
something and that'll make me happy or
i'll have a relationship that'll fulfill
me that'll bring me peace or
um i'll have some substances and that
will bring me peace
um
and
it's all just trying to heal the dis
ease of separation of lack
yeah and so that's the main pattern and
that's why the mystic traditions just
aim to point you directly inward the
direct path inward
mysticism uniting with god within and
then in that process you discover who
and what you are
and
then you feel
the peace and happiness that is innate
in that and um and then you radiate you
illumine and it's just
yeah it's just way less yeah consume me
and graspy and it's way more uh generous
serving illuminating yeah
yeah and you can feel that you can feel
that from um from people is what i've
found is especially you know you and i
are in nls and
um
[Music]
no one in society yeah
um
and
and we'll get into that i think um
that's going to be a big part of this
conversation um
but i feel what i what i've noticed is
interacting with people um within nls it
doesn't matter what stage of the journey
that they're at the fact that they're
there and showing up for themselves in
that way it creates an automatic respect
like an automatic level of respect
and and when i see it it's like
it's um
and get to interact with it and you know
like talking with you i got to speak
with corey on the previous one um and
then like even off the interview screen
off insights um
just
you can when i think illumined ones i
think like it's a spectrum like yeah we
could talk about enlightenment and we
could say that it's like this you know
like
like an enlightened being an illumined
one but for me it's like this spectrum
of of um
[Music]
those who are
like willing to go the distance
you know
that's really that's really and when i
see that quality it's like i want to
highlight that persona because there's
somebody on that wherever they are it
doesn't matter where the [ __ ] they are
excuse me i don't know if we can curse
on them of course yeah yeah okay cool
um
and so it doesn't matter where they are
at all and
for me to even try to put a placement on
that in itself is you know that would be
inaccurate anyways it'd be a fallacy so
um
yeah but i i find that there is
it's going to be
the resin gain as much as i do from
every conversation because i'm starting
to view actually for the last four or
five months of my life every every
interaction has become
um a teaching moment
you know like i learn in every
interaction so like every individual is
my teacher
is is what i'm seeing and it's like
dude like get this out to the world like
people need that you know like people
it's just to absorb the energy and the
perspective like two people having a
conversation like you and i and just to
like see that mechanism
in itself that energy is gonna carry
over and people are gonna have some sort
of an experience what that's gonna be
that's you know up to
source so let that play out
and that also plays into the
simultaneity of things where you have
always already free being now
and also at the same time there being an
appearance like you said of different
levels or different stages just like us
10 years ago versus now
um and anytime you meet someone in nls
you have this auto respect for them
because they're in the process
of fully getting through any lack any
separation any limiting beliefs and just
coming from the same place that bentino
comes from that the team comes from and
that
is aligned
most
first
foremost with the mission which is
igniting global awakening
and
the
proliferation of the frequency of
shambhala which is spiritual kingdoms
across the entire planet where all basic
needs are met where all potential is
being fully actualized and
where all are awake where all are
playing where all are creating
generating um prosperity and energy and
lucrative abundance in finance and in um
in in food and in water and it's just so
technology it's just so
everyone feels this in the deepest of
their hearts in the collective which is
that it's that it's what they know is
possible heaven on earth but that yeah
so that's what
we're aligned with yeah
i love that i love that uh i want to
dive into that it felt like the word
that popped to me is the word just
possibility in general it's it's such an
elementary word but it's such a also
like
it's it's a hidden gem i feel like in
any secret structure
um where it's like coming from
possibility is
the key to everything it's the key to
unlocking you know this any anything
that's locked i guess you could say even
um
[Music]
it's so cool yeah that's that's that
felt really good yeah so it's like
um
there's there's something that that came
up for me recently in terms of like
well
recently being like six months ago maybe
a year ago um
but
the idea of optimism
um versus someone who considers
themselves a realist right
and
what i found is like well
most most people and i don't want to you
know could be generalizing here but most
people i'd say it's safe to say
when they hear the word realist they're
talking about what is currently
appearing in their reality right and
what they perceive to be like like this
is real
like you know physical objects and
things like that
um
and so
not even being aware of the metaphysical
aspects that can create and shift
you know
like
just through a state change
just through you know going in and
again like becoming acquainted with who
you are
um
so you take that word realist and you're
you're now
you know you're i'm a realist like i i
go based off of what is appearing to me
is essentially what you're saying it's
like or is essentially what someone is
saying
and then optimism to me is like
i i go based off of what is unseen or
solution based thinking i i look at it
as
uh or
seeking seeking possibilities in every
single situation and what i find is on
this path that i'm on
the the
the depth of possibility gets
exponentially wider every day
and like you know like
the depth of what is possible becomes
just
um
you know it's more instantly available
and it's just wider like the scope of
what you could see as possible and how
you can actually metaphysically tune
into it and create from the uncreated to
bring that into creation
and you're not um
like that's my reality you know what i
mean like that's realism to me now it's
like yeah of course
you can you can create from
the uncreated and of course you can
bring it you know
um so it's so cool to have like nl
without nls that wouldn't be as a um for
me
i i would say
nls has fast tracked me in my in my
faith and conviction in that um
and and also just um opening up to
others because i've always been like a
kind of in my as ben would say stinky
little pond i was the the self seeker
you know like to myself kind of doing my
own thing
um
and doing group work didn't really
didn't really resonate with me for a
long time
and i think coming into nls it was like
the first things that came up was just
all of this [ __ ] fear
you know about you know like yeah i'm
great in the in the i guess you could
say 3d world like i can you know put me
in a room with um
rappers you can put me in a room with
businessmen you can put me in a room and
i you know i thrive
it doesn't matter who's in the room i'm
very adaptable but then you know put me
in a room full of people who who
also know themselves it's like the
standard gets raised
it's beautiful though because like that
that gave me so much um
like just seeing it seeing the example
of it gave me so much like will to to do
the same for myself like show up for
yourself damn it you know like
this is what you want anyways so like
show up for yourself let's do this you
know and that's the energy that i get
with nls it's just like it's this
constant like this loving
nurturing
um
guidance to like
there's nothing that you could do that
is more embarrassing than anyone else
here has ever done or been in person so
like let that go and just be
like allow yourself to be and this
it's such a great environment for that i
can't i can't speak um good enough
things about nls so
i know i went on a few different
directions there yeah
so many good threats came up um yeah
yeah one of them was that
okay
so you spoke
of the shift from
objective to subjective
so
to possibility
so we have this obsession or this focus
on the object
and
one could say that um the entire
spiritual journey basically begins with
shifting from focus or attention or
perception on the object to like the
very line of perception itself
and then to the very subject or the
perceiver
so
nice that that is sort of like the main
part you could say of of the initial
part of the spiritual journey is that
um and then when you shift to the
subject um and you recognize that
um
the subject is actually
um
the one infinite creator it's actually
god
and
that's the same thing that's looking out
of your eyes
and out of everyone's eyes
and
so then
you realize that there's like an
eternity or an infinity to your
beingness
and that you can sort of relax your
obsession with being the body and relax
your obsession with being the thoughts
and relax your obsession with objects
and focus more on the possibilities like
you said
and this is what
i wrote in high level perception that
first book that i wrote that you're
checking out and chapter two is called
seed theory
yeah
and so in seed theory
you have
basically a
analogy that you're drawing between
the tree of possibility from the seed
and all of the possibilities that branch
hey one sec actually atlas i don't mean
to cut you off but i think it would be
powerful if you shared screen if you
have it pulled up there you could share
screen and you can click on it because i
see the illustration that you're talking
about in front of me or if you make me a
co-host i can share my screen for you
i think showing them
i just love how on point you are because
uh that's gonna make it so much better
for sure you know what i mean
yeah
okay here we go
boom
sweet so that's chapter four go to
chapter two
okay
oh you're right that is chapter four
okay
see theory right here well it's like a
map
nice
sweet so
um
okay
so
if
if you tune into possibilities above
everything and you recognize that
everything that's objective
is downstream of what is subjective of
what is
the focus or the imagination or the will
or the creativity of god of the one
infinite creator so
then you feel more and more
okay so why don't i tune in to that seed
level the possibility space and i make
this analogy with the tree
and i see that out of all of my like
possible trajectories in life
that i can persistently
constantly focus on and choose my
preferred state and my preferred
frequency which is oneness shambhala
service coming from there and also
seeing in that north star position
igniting global awakening the mission
architecting shambhalas across the
planet and nothing being higher than
that and so then
your
all of your focus
in imagination is on that
and as god as the one infinite creator
with the stylus painting
and so then guess what happens is within
five years 10 years 15 years this entire
planet is saturated with spiritual
kingdoms and then guess what happens is
somebody 15 years later
turns and asks themselves hey
how did this all happen how did the
subject or the imagination become object
of shambhala's across earth
and this is how it happened because we
focused on the possibility space we
focused on the root the root or the
substratum is the fact that you are god
you are the one infinite creator you
have the [ __ ] stylus in your
imagination and so
we manifest
the external and so
focusing on the possibility space is so
critical and also focusing
simultaneously on the seed level of
basic needs being met is what enables
people from around the world to be able
to have clean drinking water and have
food and have shelter and not have
diseases
and just have energy and abundance so
that they themselves can also turn
inward and ask themselves the question
who am i what is i what is my nature and
also get through any layers of
separation or lack or location or these
types of things and then it becomes
easier for us to prosper as a planet so
the basic needs which you could say are
the physicality
actually fuel the subjective as well so
they're in a feedback loop with each
other the subjective and the objective
so that's why it's so important to have
the simultaneity of both
yes yeah totally i totally agree and
it's funny i think um during a session
before that ben had uh you'd mentioned
the simultaneity and it i remember even
just how much
joy was in your voice and you're like
dude i just love you man just the
simultaneity thing is what keeps me and
i
i felt that i felt that like like deeply
too because that that's um that's
something that i that i
you know i notice i especially
it's been it's been a um
kind of front and center factor for me
in my seeking as well it's the
simultaneity of like because because at
this moment that we create separation we
are outside of the realms of the whole
in terms of or within it creating the
illusion of
being outside of the you know the whole
so it's uh
it's it's cool though it's nice when you
notice that because then you realize
that you can't really ever be alone or
like you never are separate
um when you do get that outer outer
layer look at your the macro lens look
at look at what's actually going on when
we create separation
um
so i it's really cool it sucks when
you're inside of it but it's really cool
when you're on the outside of it and
you're like ah i see what i did there
yeah that's that's clever yeah
and we could even say that the whole
game is played there um do we feel like
do we feel like it's cool to
end the screen share for now or do you
feel like you want to bring something up
yeah let's yeah okay cool well actually
you know you know what real quick uh
because i do like what you did here i
did a a video
um i think on my youtube and it was it
was something along the lines of a
linear explanation of um
of
timelines yeah and and this feels a lot
like that what i did but just in a lot
more detail i drew it out like little
like just points and then high vibration
was here and lower vibrational yes are
here and then yeah they fork off with
every decision that you make in one
direction or another and just because
you go super you know deep into a lower
you know vibrational thought or whatever
doesn't mean that you can't at any given
point make a decision that will you know
even just vertically shoot you directly
up that happens too
so it's like i i love this i love this
because you gave you gave really good
examples alcohol and cannabis abuse and
then like what that's pretty like that's
pretty neutral it's like coasting to
fill this void and then marry like very
average marion average partner but then
you could see at some point you know the
alcohol and cannabis abuse like that
could have led at some point to gang
involvement or it could have led to a
jail sentence and then you know and then
overdose at 27 at a club like i
to me that's that's such a um
it's such it's real you know in terms of
like what's what what
um
can can happen now but like the the cool
thing is is like
what we perceive as like you know lower
vibration higher vibration uh i would
say
in the earlier states of seeking and
sometimes still even actually even now
like
that
that there is
there can be that illusion of that lower
frequency um being worse because you
feel constricted or being worse right
like worse or better because you feel
constricted but really in the macro lens
like all of this is of the same nature
you know like
this the jail sentence and like that is
a valuable lesson for a soul
it's a super valuable lesson for a soul
and then you know then you go up here
company founder investor mentor like
that feels great but in relation to what
our society has viewed as
success you know and so it's it's really
cool i don't know i love this so much i
hope that people take time to actually
just like really dissect what you did
here because it's it's really cool i got
it immediately the second i saw it yeah
yeah it's it's so
relatable because we see the tree and we
see the branches and we see our own
possibility space very much like this
with a with a fork point and a decision
and then are we going in the direction
of our our highest possibility or are we
going in a direction of a more medium or
a lower possibility and we feel this all
the time and uh and like you said you've
done videos explaining timelines
explaining the style of you could also
call this like choice architecture um in
in computer science in computer science
called decision trees
and so you're
it's just so relatable across so many
different facets of of of creation and
it's um and that's why you can capture
it right away for those that have even
like lightly um
like lightly began exploring it it's
just so relatable um
so
yeah i feel like uh i i have one i have
a thread from a little bit ago but do
you want to do you have another thing
you want to mention about it
i did have one last thing yeah go for it
that just kind of popped in which was
it's really it's it's really interesting
because at any given point you know you
go through awakening here and
it might it might be like a really
traumatic one and then you go into wait
like you're i like this up line that
went directly up here i'm not sure if it
went up or down but involvement in data
scandal and then so there's a triangle
here but anyways so like at any given
point so like this is very linear right
what we're what we're seeing here but
then also at any given point there is
that like simul simultaneously right
there can be that spontaneous awakening
that happens where you just disappear
from this spot and you appear right here
your new stance is just automatically
here because something significant
shifted internally something significant
enough shifted internally where that
that that reality no longer can exist in
your uh experience so that was the only
thing that i wanted to add is like while
it's linear there's also this like
this uh property of it
the potential of it being the quantum
leapiness
yes yeah nailed it yeah for sure
like where you can just like dissolve as
air for a second and then just like pop
into another area yeah
yeah
and and
with no real explanation and that's
where you know you might have some law
of confusion come in and you know
because there's dissonance between the
old reality and the new reality and all
that yeah so
yeah super that's currently what i'm
experienced but go ahead you had a you
had a thread actually that you were
going to go on and then maybe we could
shift into personal experience perfect
so
what came up earlier was
where the entire game
of source or the one infinite creator is
being played
and
you could say that the entire game
is being played
at
the
event horizon
and so
where
the
sense of self
even arises in the first place is where
the game is being played so
if you're feeling
a
sense of being located in the body and
being
contracted with your thoughts and with
separation
that the shift is more and more out of
your obsession with the stars and the
planets and the relationships between
them
and it's more and more closer to the
event horizon
which is at the center of the galaxy
which is
disappearing into the singularity
wow
and
from the singularity then you can emerge
as a full shepherd
as as completely pure
and you'll and you'll continue purifying
of course but that
the the shift is really to like seeing
these analogies like
you're you know the very the very eye
itself
is
a microcosm of the macrocosm of a galaxy
um right and so yeah
so
the patterns are everywhere
it's so fractal it's recursive
and the patterns are everywhere and it's
up to us to like tune in to those
patterns and wonder
like
might it be
that
all i have to do is understand
the nature of
black holes
and
the nature of that being a singularity
and the nature of
them
both
which is a recent finding which i think
is fascinating that black holes are not
only
consumers
or
uh taking in
the light transmitters as well right
they're also creating they're also
creating stars and light and
so
so the very the very fact that um
that
you have a
sort of like an indescribable mystery
that is like
uh
both like
like both generating like infinite
like actualizing infinite potential in
the form of like stars and planets and
explorations but at the same time it's
understanding itself through these mind
body spirit complexes through the
through this this um
like indescribable like power to know
which is
uh
like
it's
yeah you can't even describe what's
happening like neuronally
uh at the heart level in the gut level
and how all of these you know 30
trillion cells are undergoing some sort
of a comprehension process on behalf of
that infinite mystery that we are wow
and so
yeah just these patterns and the whole
game is played right here like if you
can just tune into this
you can
you can like recognize it
you can realize it you can
experience it more and more in your
moment-to-moment breathing and
and you'll be it more and more at the
level of your frequency of the level of
your vibration
and then you have this conviction that
sets in all of these
and then this
the
the further and further purification of
where you're coming from in service
and
and to the rest of your self-awakening
and
and if you just stay at that like source
point you can feel when you deviate a
little bit into separation or into your
uh persona your ego your costume your
identity your self image you wanting to
extract from the conversations and the
environment and get validation and try
and get some peace and happiness from
outside and have an argument with
somebody because you don't recognize
them as yourself as well and so if you
just play the whole game at that source
point
at that event horizon you can see like
buddha called it dependent origination
like the whole game is played right
there and you just fork from dependent
origination the first link is
you're either avidia or vidya you're
either ignorant or you have knowledge
from that source point from that very
because everything's intertwined in its
expression from that point
and that's what's and that's what you
could say is this the sticker paper
knowledge and the sticker on the sticker
paper which is which is ignorance but um
that duality's collapsed and what not as
well but there's a simultaneity that's
really important to recognize there
which is that from that point
if i just
really clearly and vigilantly know
myself and just watch the way i express
i can tell when i'm expressing from the
place of
complete unity like zamir and atlas are
one with itself it's just truth with
itself or reality with itself love with
itself
um
and less so oh it's a separate character
called atlas and a separate character
called zamir and that's two separate
people are having a conversation and so
yeah that's like the shift yeah
yeah yeah this and um i remember
i think uh it was in the free online
enlightenment training that ben did i
believe
um where he described you know
the tablecloth talking to itself which
is what i believe you're pointing to
right now which is i love that i love
that
analogy yeah it's super cool um
i had a really cool actual experience um
i when i oh samir i just noticed i have
i have a kleenex so we could we could
we could even show it so yeah yeah like
this make puppets yeah like yeah like
this basically talking to itself nice
you have one too
yeah exactly
points in the tablecloth talking to
itself
so that's actually yeah so so the idea
is maybe we should clarify a little bit
because we know what we're talking about
but maybe they don't
but the idea is this is that you know
all of creation is let's say this this
white
piece of paper and that
all the little you know
individuations me and atlas let's say
are um having a conversation right now
and we could say that we're two separate
beings that you guys can see are clearly
not connected at the hip physically or
anything like that but
you know on a metaphysical level
what it is is just source creation
talking to itself
as the tablecloth and it's a yeah
this is going to be really funny i love
this
so yeah
yeah it is
um and i had i the other thread that i
wanted to follow with you um i like i
like the word thread by the way i really
love that yeah um
that that you mentioned that because
it's like also the branch i just want to
say like in the tree nice right yeah
okay
yeah yeah very cool
so it's like um
that that black hole which is which is
creating and it's also
destroying at the same time essentially
and you could say comprehending is
another way to say it also which is
i
yeah i love that i love that so much
eating and comprehending
yeah yeah that's even more and that's
actually that's actually what's what's
more accurately happening in that
scenario so i like that
um
because destroying sounds really you
know it's messy and can have
connotations to it so
um
i had a very interesting experience i've
only sat with aya once uh ayahuasca once
before plant medicine and because that
was never really a heavy part of my
journey but i did it um i did i did feel
called to it i had you know i was
invited about
three times the first two times it
didn't work out and then the third time
they say you know like sometimes it'll
just enter your life and it's it's meant
to be when it happens so
um i listened to that that
piece of
that permission slip i guess you could
say and and so when i when i received
that
and i went to sit the first night i
didn't have any experience at all i was
trying to have an experience like i was
really wanting to
um because everyone sitting in the
circle was having
[Music]
their own experiences never really make
myself i just i felt like i wanted to
but
so it wouldn't happen nothing happened
second night um i had a really great
facilitator who i want to shout out on
this actually his name is bearhart
ceputo and um
incredible incredibly integral
um
i
i don't even know what to call him
because he's
he could be a shaman medicine man but
he's far more than that i don't want to
put him in a box so just a really really
awesome person who i will have on this
podcast as well
um we actually have already started
talking about it but
so we're sitting there and he goes you
know in most traditional circles they're
going to tell you
don't disrupt the circle too much you
know try to stay within this box but he
holds the space where it's like there is
no limit no limit like if you
he's like give like if you feel the
laughs coming like give it all you've
got like this you have this moment to
embrace your healing in that moment like
go for it
and i knew
going into this and i don't want to talk
too much about the specifics because
that can dilute the actual experience
that was shown
um and kind of water it down but what i
do want to say was i did have this this
experience during it where
i felt like my body was kind of in half
and i felt like a black hole
where one half was just continuously
like i was at that point that you were
talking about
just that and and i was i felt trapped
there the whole time i didn't like it
you know
i didn't like it but but it was like
eventually i surrendered you know like i
surrendered so i had a really blissful
experience and i was laughing my way
through it and and i was
simultaneously purging
like crazy but i was laughing as i was
purging and and just having this really
blissful experience that was just like
everything became so comical like and
and i discovered a laugh actually that i
had that i'd never let out in my life
and this laugh came out of me
and my friend um drew was there and his
partner uh is now is now um
mother of his child
um congrats to you guys as well if
you're watching this um
they they
she goes oh my god i remember hearing
her as i'm like
facing a bucket laughing my laughing
like and i'm like oh we're dancing right
now you know like i'm going through it
and
she goes i've literally never heard that
sound come out of a human being before
that i made that i was making it was
like it was deep man because like it was
it was coming from
an uncreated space is what it felt like
like this was coming straight from
uncreation into creation and there was a
there was a birth happening and it was
so beautiful so experiencing that
physically in your body
yes
there's you know there was it was
induced right but there was something
that can't be unfelt about that
that when you're there and now i can
resonate with what you're saying just
going there without any medicine and i
can go there into a meditative state and
experience kind of the same thing it's
definitely not the same thing but it's
the the essence of it is there
and it's so cool man i i i um so yeah i
just wanted that felt fun to share so
there was no real purpose but yeah
it's deep deep uh
purpose because entheogens
mean unleashing god or the divine within
and so when you when we play with
entheogens
they're serving our journey of
healing
transmuting any of the layers of
separation and
and lack and uh
location that we've built up the
conditioning nice and so they're
they're helping us shred all of those
and then the thing is is to not just
take the gondola ride of the antiogen
and then go right back down
but it's to
have a practice
at the same time where you can like you
said basically
revisit through your own just meditation
concentration realization abiding
recognition of yourself as the absolute
and just doing that
in five minutes a day 10 minutes a day
at the beginning of the day just relaxed
and just breathing
and just meditating on that
and there you go it's it's yeah yeah
purposefully there like we we created
all of the entheogens for
our own awakening process and you we
could even go and say that
um
the stoned ape hypothesis
which is
which is
in many ways why we're here is that we
millions of years ago
discovered
magic mushrooms
and that we
by eating those
created
higher cognitive ability to do things
like vibrate these vocal cords
into some sort of symbol symbology and
meaning that would then be comprehended
by the other mbs mind body spirit
complex entity and then we would take
over a whole planet and build
civilization and rockets and and
spaceships and energetic abundance and
all these things that are emerging um so
we're an extension of fungi on a
physical level this is a very this is a
very very important point um that yeah
that this is so important um
and i kind of want to get the exact um
number and i think i have the exact
number but i'm just gonna double check
and i'm pretty sure it's the exact
number it is the exact number great so
650 million years ago we divided from
fungi into animals
so
if you look at the biological tree of
life itself
from the single cell organisms
billions of years ago into the
multi-cell organisms
into the fungi
into the animals into
humans we come from the same it's called
abiogenesis it's the singularity point
on earth of where the first cell emerged
and then it proliferated into the
millions of species that exist today but
that we originate from
that same source point but from that
source point what is more
uh
what is more recent or close to that
source point then
humans then than chimps is fungi so
fungi is a decentralized network of
intelligence which then humans are
basically intelligent decentralized
network and that's what the one infinite
creator is an intelligent decentralized
network at work yeah and so it's just a
physical manifestation of the
non-physical and what's cool is that you
mentioned we consumed it right so
there's that like we were acting as a
black hole we consumed it
at zero point and then what came from
that there was something that was
created from that which is evolution of
the being
um wow so cool
that's so cool
insights
insights baby
simulation baby
fire fire um
yeah i love this
i love this so um
do you do you have somewhere that you
feel you want to take this i love the
flow of this it feels so good
yeah it feels so strange
yeah
very organic
i feel a good place for us to chat would
be about um no limits society and so for
both of us and on our journeys as well
so i feel like we could transition to
that
um love it
sweet and
and
it and just
what we talked about in the first
uh hour or however however long
i would even encourage you guys
watching on both of our channels i would
encourage you guys to um to
to re-watch the first hour and to in a
sense like pause and take some notes
along the way and like
and like if something came up that we
talked about that is like well what is
abiogenesis then you go and you look it
up
right that kind of thing um
and then you like research that a bit or
if something came up around anthogens or
if something came up around this event
horizon and this comprehension and this
creation and the ability to like
meditate on that
um
and or we're just shifting more and more
away from the object subject and just
all of those different things
um to take your time with like
processing or comprehending those
um and then reaching out to zamir and i
in the comments um if you guys have any
questions or any insights um and then
we'll we'll jump in and play with you on
that
love that
sweet and then
yeah so um yeah no limit society um
is
incredible it's it's basically um if you
take
um
like some of the most
like it's like the navy seals of
spirituality if you if you yeah if you
take um like the highest level like
buddhist
um realized and merge it with the like
highest level vikings that are that are
um
constitutionalized as actualizing the
planet's fullest potential and you like
merge those two together
and so
um
yeah the
um the the mission is igniting global
awakening and we do so by training free
agents in um in self-realization as well
as in self-actualization
and
um there's many different like programs
um that we offer we offer meditation
mastery which is a powerful 30-day
program um to just train yourself in
concentration and realization meditation
conviction um
and also um
in this basically this ongoing exclusive
training program that bentino and the
team offer
and it's it's purposely like exclusive
um it's purposely like in terms of there
being like a barrier to entry because
there's a there's got to be like a high
level of earnestness
and alignment with the mission even
before
like
joining in the first you could say
co-centric circle like getting into the
first co-centric circle even before you
move into like proximity in the same
geographic let's say area as the team
actualizing the mission there's like the
first barrier which is just no limit
society in general which is the online
ongoing exclusive training experience
and
um
and that's where you begin
like understanding like some of the
foundational content first and foremost
about self-realization
self-actualization basically the
teachings
um
which you could say are a distillation
of
not only this collective but the
cosmos's
uh essence
and
important distinction right there
actually yeah
very
yeah please go ahead and say that uh and
then we'll continue why did you pick up
on that because um i i do ah that's i
want to think about that i want to give
that or really tune in to that because
so the concept of wanderers in the law
of one
resonated with me the moment that i
heard it
and
i was very careful immediately not to
allow that to be an ego point
but to
to say oh if that is
who i am then
if that is what i'm here to do and and
that feels that way
well
there's got to be some sort of training
ground for that
um available
and
it like quite literally that was my
thought process like there there's got
to be some sort of because i'm like i
don't know what to do with that
information to be real
like i don't know what to like
like i didn't at that point when i
discovered the concept of wanderers
um although i
i did in a sense have the pointings of
the law of one teachings that i started
to dive into at the point there at that
point so there was that was very helpful
but um i think the distinction there um
that i that i was
excited about
was
just the fact that it that
that
these materials that i was
coming
to learn about
that they led me to somewhere where
there was
the possibility of expansion within um
you know those concepts so like abraham
hicks um love one teachings bashar
and and taking it to the and like really
dissecting it and taking these concepts
and ideas and also you know sages and
mystics like mr gadata um uh ramana
mahershi and and uh he's it's cool right
now uh ben's really loving neville
goddard
uh and it's so vast you know like there
is no
it's it's not about the individuals at
all it's about the pointings that we get
and the pointings are all relevant right
and so there's there's a distillation of
it in nls that that excites me
um a lot
so that was what i was i guess yeah
that's the same that i was picking up on
the distinction between like the
collectives
um
like
religions
and between what's going on on the
cosmological
the level of cosmological teachings
um so coming from
yeah coming from the universal teachings
of potentially advanced civilizations
and entities that are superior in terms
of progress to this collective and
taking those teachings and merging them
with the the this collective's best
stuff
so that's basically what we mean and
then
um then there's so many great
within no limit society once you sort of
go through like the orientational
content the foundational content then
you get added into
a system called catas which are a place
for you to do the work it's a place for
you to integrate the teachings with
about 20 others in these each
in these catas which are basically
sanskrit word for house or abode and you
have like kata guides which is zamir and
i are both cater guides and so these are
people that have sort of went through
doing the work and have went through the
process of purifying where they're
coming from and tuning in more and more
into the shepherding consciousness where
you're coming from a place that's most
interested in the process of the 20
people that are in your cata and so you
want to serve them as best as possible
to ask them good questions to have them
tune into their process to wake up more
to purify themselves etc and so that
cater process happens and then there's
you know there's a more you could say
exclusive even more than nls is another
you could say more exclusive ring which
is generally just continuo and the core
team and what's forming more and more as
like an extended team that's expanding
more and more and that
this is really the you could you could
view it as like the sun
right this is the sun
and then you have like mercury
and you have venus and so this is sort
of like the corn the core team and then
the and then the extended team and then
earth is like sort of where people are
shifting from more and more
into you know seeing as god sees more
and more into being aligned constituted
as just a mission and so we have all
these great analogies that help people
like when they jump from
from earth to being interested in the
teachings that's like them shifting more
and more to venus um they're like
they're like in the spaceship you can
teleport yeah yeah yeah i tell them yeah
or yeah there you go quantum leap yeah
so that's yeah no limit society in a
nutshell um
which i've been a part of for almost a
year now and zamir
what are you on how many months now
um since the meditation mastery so five
months is it four or five months i was
going to say yeah almost half a year as
well yeah yeah
and so yeah so we would love also if you
guys um
enjoyed what we just shared you can
check out the links in both of the video
bios on both of our channels we'll have
no limit society link down there and you
guys can join um
and
just if this resonates with you because
this is like there's no place there's no
place like this
on earth
where
the
the priority is the spiritual navy seals
like the priority is being a buddhist
viking it's like
there's
coming from the future which is it's
like coming from 2035 where this whole
civilization is already enlightened and
prosperous and abundant and then just
basically retracing our steps and like
reverse engineering that process in our
in our daily um creation and
um and purifying ourselves in the
process yes um of all of that which is
which is really actually something this
is a beautiful thread to to go off on
actually in our own
experience with sorry did i cut
you off or did you okay so
when like i i love the the um idea of
like ascended masters which to me is you
know uh
it's like someone who's mastered
manifestation or creation and has
ascended you know they've their ascended
masters so
it's it's like width and height i guess
you could say for is how i kind of view
it
um
and
so like i that's what this feels like
nls feels like a training grounds for
that becoming an ascended master
and and not only that but also you know
um the service to others component of it
so it was you know it's the national i
would say the um
uh focus of the whole training ground
creating catas
groups where we can we can interact with
each other and
um
and if eventually it resonates with you
you can become a guide or you you want
to step into that level of service
that's there's an opportunity to become
a kettle guide and then learn from that
side of the spectrum
um or that that part of the experience
so there's so much
available within this i'm not sure if i
said what i wanted to say
but there was
oh so yeah okay so so essentially what i
wanted to maybe give people an insight
into
is
the like how is this showing up for you
in your own journey right now like at
this moment like how how how is this
mechanism really
um and maybe you can just talk about
your
own experience or a shift that you're
going through right now and then it'll
it'll organically come up you know how
it's been a part of that
uh but i think that would be a powerful
testimonial also just to share nice bro
totally and then um same thing right
back at you afterward
um love it
and that'll be probably a good place to
rap
um yeah
so
yeah for me um right now going through
the experience of
like at the at the causal level
just going so deeply and subtly into
that which you could say is like where
you're coming from
where i'm coming from
and at that like seed level again like
we said seed theory
right
at that causal level
seeing where my my
core limiting belief or my core
assumption
is that
is that i am on whole
and so then
from from that
core
limiting belief assumption
is then the
the manifestation in the in the mind the
subtle as well as then in the physical
of then uh wanting to get something to
feel whole
so wanting to get like a validation
um wanting to be like seen as a teacher
um
just
and and it doesn't and it doesn't feel
good and like there's there's like it's
being reflected
and it it feels way better it doesn't
feel good because it doesn't feel
um whole it still feel it felt unwhole
and then it's getting reflected and in
that process like the investigation or
the inquiry like retracing all the way
to that causal level and investigating
like what were my assumptions like in my
childhood and in my life like growing up
without a dad
um
wow
and so then there's an automatic
assumption of like my picture of being
raised by just my mom
does not fit the classic picture of all
my friends that i go and hang out with
where it's mom and dad and a brother or
sister or whatever
and
and then just really healing that like
really just shining the light
of awareness love light on that at that
causal level
and seeing how the i am that awareness
love light is prior to that causal level
and just really bringing that forth into
illumination
and
then just naturally there's a
transmutation
at the causal level of the i am on
wholeness to i am whole
and then i am whole gets to express
itself more and more into
the mind and into the physical and and
it feels just a lot more light
um and so that's that's what i would say
my core right now of my experience of
what i'm going through and it's because
of this container like it's because of
bentino it's because of the team it's
because of you got to just take it from
the understanding that after like 15
years of studying like you talked about
ascended masters after 15 years of
studying the patterns
of how consciousness expresses itself
and understanding the nature
there's just the level of of mastery
that is present in the field and that is
able to really tune into things that are
this subtle and and shepherd other
selves to tune into things this subtle
and then to purify where they're coming
from and serve the mission
at a more actualized highest possible
level so that's on my end
and do you feel like commenting on that
before so good
cool
it's so good yeah because i i resonate
with it one that's it's uh i think we're
at very similar
uh
at least it looks in it like it felt the
same as what you were describing
um
where where it is you know
i think on the journey
what's what's really cool about nls and
uh this is what i'll say
um in response to that on the
having the container of nls and having
the reflections be made available to you
and
and also
being trained to spot the subtleties
like we're being trained to we've been
we've we've been trained and we're
continually being trained to to like our
attention is being brought back to the
subtleties
why
to desensitize i feel
um
ourselves not and when i say desensitize
i i kind of mean it in a reverse way
where it's like not like to not be so
reactive to rather to allow yourself to
be
just present with your [ __ ]
and and allow yourself to see the fruits
of what happens when you do that and
when you allow yourself to go there and
see how indestructible you are
you said something a long time ago to me
um
on actually i think it was a kid a guide
training call where you said it in there
where safety equals indestructibility
and that's exactly what's being shown
to us and as individuals in this
container and it with each individual
experience i hear it from from each
person as well you know their own
experience like they always come to us
realize that ah and i realized i can't
be touched by that it's a what's that in
a chorus of miracles nothing real can be
threatened um nothing unreal exists
that's one of my favorite i haven't even
hopped into the course in miracles but
like read that and and got it started
like
it got i it's funny i discovered that
saying before i discovered accords to
miracles nothing real can be threatened
nothing unreal exists and at a certain
point i thought that i came up with it
on my own
which is really funny because i was
saying it
anyways and then i discovered a course
in miracles i was like it came from
somewhere
so in a sense i did um
[Music]
but
yeah so so that's what's what's kind of
unique about this container is
the
the opportunity to really do the seeking
work
um
in a way where you're supported by other
individuals who are going through
their own processes and their own things
and also
in a way that doesn't um
i really like that it's not hippie-ish
you know and and i think that there is a
sense of um
uh of knowing why we're not doing it
that way
um that that has been clearly
um
[Music]
conveyed to each member of nls
why
like that that hippie-ish way of
approaching it and and i don't mean this
in a way of judgment of hippies for the
record uh what this is is more of a
pointing to
a maturity
in the balance of love and wisdom
and um
i'm not sure if i should i feel like
that's a really great like big subject
that we could go into i don't want to go
like down that rabbit hole just yet it's
a good point that's important that's
good that you mentioned and then also
just to briefly clarify um
in that cater guides call i remember the
context of it it was it was somebody in
a keita had um arose the experience of
unsafety
and then
yeah and then um
corey uh brought up that like to reflect
on like
where is the unsafety and bentino does
this a lot too but show me some of the
unsafety give me a little piece of it um
and then corey said that line that
the only true real safety is absolute
indestructibility and that's just so so
good yeah safety equals
indestructibility um and that's that's a
good one so there's the context for that
so basically we have profound little
nuggets that are shared like that and um
and so now i would like to do yeah your
um your experience as well if you feel
like it's good timing for that and then
we can wrap
perfect cool
i love it
i um so if i feel into my experience
it's
right now in this moment because that's
all there really is um
i i definitely
feel like a shift has already occurred
in terms of
um where i feel myself coming from
nowadays and today even
um there's there's been this process
that we've been undergoing in nls where
we're we're coming from the end result
essentially
and i feel
that
for some time in this process there was
a lot of confusion between my old self
and the self that i was becoming because
there was
parts of the old self that just could
not survive in this new version of self
that i'm creating myself to be self
actualizing myself as
um
and so
similar to what you were saying where
it's like
my process kind of has been looking like
it is continuing to look like
this
this going to the root
like i i did i never thought of it in
the way that you mentioned it which is
the causal layer
but there was there was a process that i
went through um actually while i had
covid about a week and a half ago
and i i felt like
because nothing real can be threatened
and nothing unreal exists that
i was already
vibrationally feeling pretty low so i
was already um
in the vicinity of those lower thought
forms so it was a perfect environment
for shadow work to occur and my
conviction was such that
um i
i didn't
i didn't uh feel like it would drag me
down further rather it was just a really
like great condition and perfect point
for me to do the work
and when i when i did it um
i went through this kind of
loop
like kind of reversed i i went backwards
in time
into myself if that makes sense
and
this is all imaginary i guess you could
say and
to myself as a child and you know to my
and even beyond that so like myself as
like just coming into existence
and then
what manifested out of that and and i
and i and i went with the preconceived
notion by the way i that
all is creation and that
i have created the world that i live in
the this earth that i live on i created
it so i went with that as like my kind
of
my um
intuitive birthing point i guess you
could say of this experience
and so when i did that i felt um
i felt a lot of deep
pain in like that that our world is in
and i
i was like well
my judgments of this world
are what have created my experience of
this world i know that so if i can if i
can
come from a place of acceptance
and and say that i am all of this like
all of this trauma that i'm observing
right now like i am that so i am and i
started going through like i wrote out a
list and like i let myself get really
angry and i let myself get like really
um
just all these things that i don't
normally exhibit like all these emotions
that i would normally not because i just
don't see a point in it really it's not
that i'm suppressing it i just don't
want to
but i was like well let me go there then
if i'm so if i feel like i'm so
comfortable with let me actually go
there
and allowed myself to and
and some of the things that i wrote out
were i am a murderer i am uh
and you know there were
these these
individuals in society that i would
maybe have a judgment towards that i
could come to in this experience in that
time frame of this process
to actually have a genuine love and
acceptance for regardless and see them
as creator not in approval of the acts
or actions but so so there was this
this clean separation that that occurred
in that process for me
um
of
and this this is this is where the juice
is i think in my process right now was
through that i was able to see how i am
how my judgment of myself has been
creating this unworthiness
to be to exist
at all like i have this judgment of
myself as being or i had this judgment
of myself as being less
so on the other end murderer is on one
end of the spectrum and then
the other end of the spectrum is um i
don't know
like
people who i look up to and um
who who i see as very enlightened beings
you know things like that and like
comparing myself to them and uh
things like that so that so like two
ends of the spectrum of my human
experience that i wanted to actually
just go through and say i am all of that
i am so so i allowed myself to go there
but what i realized in that was that i
am um
that that it was okay to act like i felt
the
relaxation happen that kind of just
completion in that moment where it was
like i feel like i can actually sense
that it's there and therefore it exists
and therefore
i have access to it and therefore and
therefore and therefore and therefore
and it started becoming more of a
possibility whatever it is but like that
that
i think it's just deep inner acceptance
that just started to just it's been
growing consistently
um every day and i have access to that
now and it's it's really beautiful
because you know i've had layers of that
in the past but i think there was a
traumatic experience that i locked
myself down in from like experiencing
that and this was a relationship that i
entered that i allowed myself to like i
was
pretty arrogant in a sense that i was
trying to awaken somebody who did not
want to be awakened right
and i was convinced that i could because
i
everything i was touching at that time
was turn into gold so of course i'm like
i i can yeah absolutely i can do god's
work you know but i didn't have the
wisdom to understand when somebody does
want to and when somebody does not want
to be awakened
um so so that caused you know quite a
karmic loop for myself and i locked
myself down and i stopped trusting
myself
um
and because there was like this self
betrayal in the process sexually as well
in the relationship where i was i knew i
shouldn't be in it anymore but i stayed
in it because the sex was so great and
things like that so there was so even
that was like a point of acceptance
along that spectrum was like i'm a
sexual deviant you know like like really
letting myself accept that and and even
if i'm not expressing it right now
but to accept that and say i am that so
that i don't have that judgment present
has changed my perception of the world
um and people who i interact with with
this real like there's a real
layer of
non-judgment that's present now that was
not there and i'm not saying it's
flawless i still have judgments but
there is this
beautiful beautiful like
backing of just love there that um
that nls has given me access to in terms
of the tools and techniques and the
teachings
um
that and the space holding you know
these containers and just seeing people
go through their process talking to
somebody like you
and hearing you be vulnerable allows me
to be vulnerable um and so it's
the power of group work you know i i did
we're coming full circle here because i
did say
i
i um had a hard time with group work
earlier on and
now i just feel like [ __ ] this is
awesome like this is so good it's so
good and yes the individual work still
gets to happen but for some reason i
made that mutually exclusive in my mind
entering into the container because well
i would say it's a
fear of intimacy that created that
experience but then once you you really
get around people you know in nls um you
you come to see like dude everyone's
here for the same reason they all just
want to know themselves as creator and
accept themselves and then as you say
express yourself as
is that what's that from
know
accept yourself it's in your bio yeah
know yourself accept yourself become the
creator the three steps yes raw
communicates in the law of one yeah
and that's it and that's you know that's
why we do these processes i'm sure to to
somebody who's never heard of this stuff
that's like why the [ __ ] would you call
yourself a murderer and why would you
sit in it you know
i look i like to i like to see it from
from that lens too and and just anyways
um
dude it's cool it's
it's really it's really um
beautiful yeah is the word thank you
yeah
it is and
you
sharing your healing and your
deepening of accepting
who you are
and you sharing how now by doing that
process
everything up until this point was just
this most beautiful precious fuel for
the flower blossoming and now like the
aroma is like the illumination
and so now you're
you're emanating more and more and then
that's where the shepherding gets to
actualize itself and that's where
the true freedom is found in that
where um
the
there's nothing more beautiful we could
say than when
um
other self feels contracted seeking
freedom and then um we
we
we shepherd through our own illumination
through our own transmutation
um and then they also get um to
transmute into a lumen um to shift from
a more contracted to a more um boundless
free energy
yeah love it love it dude that was
poetry
yeah
i love you too man so much this is
really i love you too brother i can't
wait to give you a big hug
dude yeah this was epic um
almost makes me want to start like a
a podcast with you and interview like
grow the you know what i mean like oh
[ __ ]
yeah we've had we've had a lot of uh
um
expressions of that like uh
you know like romay and corey um with
the light touch and uh sort of like
tuning into like the actualization of
that and like just um
obviously both of us now uh you know
tuning in to interviewing more people in
nls and stuff so
so um who knows there may be some uh
some juicy little uh some co-hosting
stuff that might yeah
that's pretty cute um so yeah so who
knows the little uh the
what uh the
the
you have uh the
the romaine cory and then who knows
maybe there's amir and atlas and and
then just maybe we have a
conversation with the four and like
bringing people into that as well so
there's all these great mixes uh of that
as well and so that's the power when we
come together like within no limits
society we
can move mountains together we can
actualize shambhala growing
from the hundreds into the thousands
into the millions of people just
fully awake actualized prosperous
and just an ongoing birthday party um
boom yeah oh that's you know that's from
kanye west that's from kanye west
because
because when he ran in 2020
he said i want to call my party the
birthday party
every day should be a birthday every day
should be a celebration on earth you
know that's my interpretation of the
birthday party and so
um why the [ __ ] not and it already is
for so many people that are tuned into
nature um but the stress and the anxiety
and the depression and the separation
that's not um where we're heading so um
yeah bro so much yeah there's a lot of
oh man i love you too bud and
there's so much
that uh to to the to the i just want to
make this point because it felt relevant
with what you just said to the point of
the
stress and anxiety and all that because
there's
there's sure to be people who watch this
who have experience that are
still god which is important which is
still god yeah
yes totally totally and
it's being it's it's currently naturally
being transmuted so a lot of you know
your guys's processes out there uh may
also not be yours actually none of it is
yours to to
really put it truthfully um in the first
place so i don't know i i felt like
there might be some solace found in that
that you know also take it take it easy
on yourself and give yourself the love
that you deserve you are
a um loving and loved being and you're
more than capable of
you know every single
um growth opportunity that lies ahead of
you and if you do feel called nls is a
great great place to not only
meet that bar but to exceed it and to
give that to others as well um so just
wanted to be
beautiful and so find the no limit
society links in the bio also on
simulation you can find the links to all
of zamir's
all of zamir's
insights as well as his uh his
instagram his website you can check out
all those links on simulation and then
on insights you can find my links as
well
um
and also we would love for you guys to
subscribe to our youtube channels um if
you haven't yet also um like the videos
on the channels that helps uprank them
in the algorithm um comment below with
your thoughts on the episode also share
the video if the video made a profound
influence on you share it with
other people that you feel like it would
profoundly move and let's get the word
out baby
um
beautiful and infinite love to you guys
fam thank you
yeah big love to you guys and uh i love
you buddy i can't uh this is awesome
this is so good so good thank you man
cool so good bro it's a the beginning of
a beautiful flowering creation together
so
yes yes i feel it cool bye guys love you
bye guys take care